hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
according to the metadata I'm Dave Rubin
and I've got Jen Hoffman and Sean
Hollenbach with me and let's get right
to it
okay the NSA scandal continues and
depending on what channel you're
watching this is either the most
horrific overreach of government ever or
they're protecting us and our civil
liberties are not at jeopardy I want to
start though with Fox News they just are
an endless cacophony of hilarity Sean
Hannity here is some compilation of what
Sean Hannity thought about the NSA and
spying and that sort of thing when Bush
was president that's George W Bush and
here's what he thinks about it now that
Obama's president so take a look and
then we're gonna break it down is it
right to say that for example on issues
involving national security be at the
NSA surveillance program the data mining
program the Patriot Act Guantanamo Bay
that Democrats are weak on issues
involving national security when our
techniques are working we've got the NSA
program here we've got the Patriot Act
program here you know in light of this
how close this was I it's staggering to
me that were even debating the use of
these techniques in this country even at
this time big brother is monitoring your
every move whether it be online or on
the telephone let's talk about why this
story why is this important to you
number one this is America and as
law-abiding American citizens you have a
right to privacy number two these
actions by the Obama administration are
clear very clear violation of the Fourth
Amendment which prohibits unreasonable
search and seizure number three the
Constitution it is our rule of law if we
do not respect and honor the
Constitution then anarchy and tyranny
will there follow okay so that is
exactly why I wanted to do this show and
why I started this whole thing because
the media is actually worse than the
government he loved it when it was for
Bush he hates it now that Obama is doing
the exact same thing is this just like
the height of
hypocrisy and can we expect anything
better so we just like the most i rollin
ridiculous
character now he's surpassed o'reilly
like at least o'reilly usually will
retain some semblance of you know this
is what i'm saying and i and i stick
with it if he changes his mind he says
it changes his mind yeah kennedy's out
of his mind and just will go with
whatever he thinks you know the most
right faction or whatever the market
research people at fox tell him and i
think at the time when bush was
president they were just like no you
know 9/11 just happened and patriot act
and we have to support george bush and
then they know they did their market
research which was just googling do you
hate obama check the yes box for watches
fox when they were like oh now this is
the worst thing that's ever happened so
it's we expect it it's stupid it's
obvious but the problem is it's not
obviously the viewers of fox so speaking
of the viewers do you think when the
regular viewers the people that have
been watching this guy and its millions
and millions of people that are watching
tonight so you think that the regular
viewer that digs this guy is going wait
a minute i know that he didn't believe
that a couple of years ago or they just
don't care well my dad's missing teeth
and doesn't care so i don't think you he
doesn't do any research at all using
care hit me but he'll believe whatever
they say and that's big news
oh yeah he's big that's all he watches
this fox news right love you dad but
you're an idiot but um but what i think
is so funny is that hannity is sort of
the the bizarro liberal whatever the
liberals think he thinks the exact
opposite just to just to please their
audience base it's like I hate the way
Obama choose we should stop chewing
dunno I don't know it's just Obama could
do anything and they'll just say it's
wrong yeah do you guys I'm so I'm so on
this idea that this is actually worse
now because of the media then because of
the governor because I feel like no one
ever trusts the government really but
like if we can't even trust the media
and look MSNBC is almost as bad on the
left as Fox's on the right you know the
middle just getting it wrong from the
sky yeah
to get ratings yeah which they don't get
ironic yeah that's the funny part I mean
Fox is crushing them altogether and
MSNBC is in the middle and and CNN's
getting slaughtered but if we can't
trust that we're gonna ever turn who do
you trust who do you trust in the midst
of all news excuse a little bit older
excuse to people that depend on the
television news that depend on their
news anchors and that believe that these
people are telling him the truth people
that were brought up to believe that
when you are listening to a news program
like your father my mother similar my
mother's almost 70 years old she watches
Fox News and what they say is gospel to
her because she believes these are the
authorities telling her the truth yeah I
think younger generation understands
that a that there's companies that own
these people there's people like Rupert
Murdoch there's corporations there's
advertising dollars there's all these
different reasons why certain large
media entities have reasons to kind of
skew a story a certain way or make a
story bigger and then I think you know
younger people kind of just turned the
internet more and not that's always more
helpful yeah [ __ ] on the Internet
are you saying not everything on the
internet is true
yeah I'm but I think Eddie I think
they're holding on to an older audience
and I think that's what it is and I
think older people tend to believe what
they're told from an authority because
that's kind of just the way you were
raised because they're closer to death
and judgment when you were younger you
know you didn't you know really question
authority as much of course some people
did but I think it speaks to that why
your father and my mother and another
generation of people watch Fox News
because they're like nope whatever you
say is true yeah I just wonder what
happened to getting in llego I trust him
he was empty yeah but is there really
wait I don't even who that is like CNN
or something yeah I'm gonna Google her
when I get home but is there someone in
the news really I mean thank you I know
it's me but besides me is there someone
in the news that you watch and actually
feel like this person is like
intellectually honest
and really which I was like so much just
like the most random reporting of early
reporting just [ __ ] like whatever
they're like just say it first
exactly
for some reason Anderson Cooper has this
hold I feel like on a lot of people I
know we're we're like we trust coops and
I don't know why is it's just his hair
it's just the hair and the hair and that
perfect skin I know yeah I want to marry
him sorry Jeff but I also like Lisa Ling
who I think is a really honest reporter
and I feel like she tells the full story
yeah and she's very trustworthy because
her sister was kidnapped
she's only trans we're thinking everyone
was like what her sister was kidnapped
her because she looked very emotional
when Oprah had her on and they were like
we've saved your sister noodling had the
one tear and then they booked her for
every show for the rest of her life I'm
kind of like Lisa Ling I don't trust you
I think you're - no I think she's my
famous cause they kidnapped her sister
she's well she was also she was on the
view the view on the in high school they
had this TV channel and she was one of
the one of the anchors oh you weren't
out yeah you were yeah I didn't do my
research I know what you guys are
talking about you guys were anchors on a
high school TV show oh you mean the big
closed-circuit ones everywhere or
whatever that didn't exist how that
exists when she was she older than me
this is getting so final thing on this
is should we when I was looking at this
story like I really wanted to do this
because I think it's important that
people really see it side by side like
the one opinion in the other opinion and
really just show it to everybody so they
see the [ __ ] but do you guys ever
think that we should just not cover
stories like this because it's like I
have a policy on this show and on
Twitter I don't talk about the
Kardashians because I think you that's
how you take the power away should we be
doing that kind of thing when it comes
to something like Hannity and just let
it be ignored and be for it you have to
call it out so obvious and so ridiculous
and even though it's preaching to the
choir because I'm sure a lot of people
that watch you and I'm gonna be watching
things on YouTube aren't necessarily a
fox news viewer it's so
Leyton it's like grossly blatant like
how it to be yeah those clips
side-by-side are just so outrageously
blatant and gross and to show you what
that news channel is all about that
you're like how can you not show it yeah
yeah so final thought as an artist and
someone that puts out you know comedy
and your thoughts I think do you think
there's ever a moment that you've had
where you've put out something that you
said one way and then cruelly just
absolutely said the other thing you know
just again yes we all want yeah we all
want the retweet retweet this like this
thumbs up okay let's go let's keep going
on this NSA thing because this is kind
of getting crazy so the NSA is building
right now a I believe it costs 1.7
billion dollar facility in Bluffdale
Utah which is 25 miles away from Salt
Lake City that's gonna hose hose it's
gonna house a hundred thousand square
foot data center where they're going to
be monitoring us there it is it looks
very much like a moon base or something
from Star Wars those what what you're
seeing right there are just the cooling
things to keep the computer is cool
because they are sucking that much data
and data is hot I guess and do you mind
that your tax money is going to this
type of thing to report and record and
watch you at all times well I'm kind of
glad they put it in Utah to really
monitor our natural resources like
Mormons and saltwater so that's really
good that they did it there yeah but I
actually I don't mind even when the Bush
administration was sort of watching us
yeah I I think going back to the Fox
News saying I think the people who are
being monitored aren't watching Fox News
Watchers there are people who are
calling internationally I know it's it's
not it's not ideal but I feel like if
they can stop another attack I think to
me I feel a little safer internet but
even though that now they're saying that
it's not just international calls now
that they're they have the metadata for
all of us that doesn't
and then keywords and all that so that
doesn't bother you I know I'm really
interesting so I'm just glad I can
provide ya phone call I need someone
else to be listening to me perform
that's the nation I'm just saying any
word you can any conversation just a
minute or the end of another TV credit I
want to be taken into some Jail I'm take
another Guantanamo yes now I sense light
sarcasm there but you and I mean what do
you think like we're building giant
facilities no there's no oversight the
government's just pouring money into all
this stuff first of all I'm like it's
one of those things like we've arrived
in the future and it's freaking scary
like you know it's it's kind of
terrifying and even to look at the
facility to look at what your thing like
the cooling stuff just for all that data
that they're processing the fact that
they need an entire section just to cool
down on top of ours that they're going
through it's really terrifying and I
understand the people are saying what if
it saves lives what if it prevents
another 9/11 but it terrifies me that
there's really it's kind of the wild
wild west on this they haven't really
said this is how we're gonna do it this
is the only people we're gonna listen to
I mean a then you can't profile people
it's too confusing I just don't
understand how you can have the right to
just say hey we're the government
elected by you but now we're gonna spy
on you even though most people if you
ask them and I think your opinion is
interesting because you know some people
are like if it keeps us safer that's
fine
most people are like hello I don't want
you spying on me and I don't believe in
that well if you're doing nothing wrong
then it shouldn't matter because so why
like why do they have access to
everything you do on the Internet and
your phone just because they're the
government that's right and scary I
actually think that's the weakest
argument against it because the look and
you could be doing nothing wrong and
just sending emails work emails where
you say something mean about someone you
work with which is perfectly legal or
you could be watching porn that's
perfectly legal but you don't want the
government to be like oh well we know
now know this about you and we're gonna
tell all your friends how much porn you
watch well they can be made against you
in other arenas it's kind of just like
how basic traffic stops work out just
like in basic just law enforcement cops
will you know if they decide they want
to pull somebody over they'll look for
the slightest little thing in order to
get in to try to get somebody for
something
else and they're saying what that person
was doing something wrong like a
taillight is out or they weaved one so
maybe they can be pulled over on
suspicion of drunk driving but ever the
person sober they're still kind of being
harassed because they want to racially
profile or they wanted to for some
reason pull a person over so they're
looking for the smallest thing I think
that right Lipper a slope that happens
when they start listening to your
conversations and monitoring your emails
yeah isn't the other problem that you
know Obama keeps saying well you know or
everyone keep saying that but this isn't
all getting up to Obama it's dealt with
in mid-level whatever so but isn't that
where all the abuse is gonna take place
like the SIA the Cincinnati IRS guys you
know like I don't believe Obama was you
know the lunch table in the Cincinnati
IRS office going let's do this but like
it never gets up to the highest you can
be like okay well my sister's having a
problem with her you know ex-husband so
let's target him and look for some
keywords and haul him in like it's just
I'm gonna know who's overseeing it and
what control they have and what power
they have because unions are hauling
people and for all sorts of reasons
we're saying things just based on this
you know there's like Patriot a con wild
basically right so as the guy that wants
safety since you want safety more than
privacy do do you think that we can
trust the gatekeepers who are the
gatekeepers that's the problem think
about how much data they're collecting
and then how many analysts are gonna go
look for my new show that has nothing
like you're not gonna find if Steve my
brother-in-law is cheating on my sister
I don't think I can't call it hey
Michael at the NSA can you just do quick
favor warming and you see if Steve is
cheating on my sister not the NSA and
you decide to abuse that power or use it
to get people in trouble for other
things like I didn't mean it like oh I'm
pissed off but somebody's I'm gonna call
my hookup at the NSA and be like get on
them start monitoring them but if you
work they working like your time in
Cincinnati you can you can start to
abuse things if your mid-level it's like
obviously if you're so high-profile you
can't really abused or else it's obvious
but if you're just working there you can
kind of never you want so for example
this guy Edward Snowden who released all
these documents to the Guardian he's a
mid-level contractor this guy doesn't
even have the highest levels of access
and he still was able to release all
doesn't that thing look like that it
looks yeah it looks like something out
of a sci-fi movie we're either
yo or Tom Cruise or Will Smith would
have to go in and destroy that look like
the enemy it does exactly what you're
saying though it does it's like so
postmodern now that we have exactly the
thing that in every movie we've been
told is the evil empire that they have
to go break into to protect us all from
the government that's all like that guys
one more time with the air conditioning
thing I'm picturing like like Skywalker
flying in on an x-wing and he has to
shoot right into a little hole to blow
up the solution I think what the NSA has
to do is remove all the people that work
there who wear eye patches because
they're the ones that are gonna cause
the trouble yeah generally they're
untrustworthy the eye patch people in
solving America's problems here yeah
yeah and and I don't care they can
listen to my phone call yeah all of you
with eyepatch ease feel free to comment
about Shawn Hollenbach though there's a
lot of eye patches all right one more
thing about the internet as long as
we're doing this whole NSA thing so what
the next thing that seems to be the hot
trend now is people want to figure out a
way to get offline to become to become
unglue
and to get some of their anonymity back
and you know they're saying right now
that all our keystrokes are being
monitored all that stuff I don't want to
go into all every level of the paranoia
stuff but do you guys does this idea
appeal to you and we've talked about it
on this show a couple of times before
but the idea that people are going to be
paying to erase their stuff already
there are bars that are saying you know
you're not going to wear Google glasses
here battle thing is this all the future
would you would you want to reset and
disappear from the internet think you
could good piece of advice if you want
to remove yourself off of Google move to
Madagascar like move somewhere over
there just isn't a lot going on in the
crazy animals change your name to
Jennifer Smith I actually understand
this especially because first well you
can make mistakes when you're younger
there can be things about you on the
inner that are necessarily true things
you participate in whether it's like a
television show or pictures of you out
at night those things stay and then you
evolve as a person and then you go crap
there's this whole me on the Internet
so unless you've been super savvy about
branding yourself you can either look
all over the place on the Internet or
there could be things you simply just
don't want on there I was warm at the
different last name so I have a birth
certificate in a passport that it's a
different last name and now it's legally
been changed to gentleman like that's my
legal name but was that because of a
stage name oh no I was on my mother
married someone who adopted me when I
was 11 months old so them changed shoe
that last name so my dad's last name
that I carry now instead of rather than
my mother's maiden name which is only a
birth certificate I think all the time
about changing it back to that just so
when people google me nothing comes up
so you can start with a fresh slate
because there's assumptions people make
about you and if you work in any sort of
industry and people are booking you
think really great you were great for
this oh but we googled you and found out
that you once worked in entertainment so
that's inappropriate for news or if you
were news is inappropriate for this or
you were blonde in these pictures and
that confuses us because we like you
better brunette I mean it's so
ridiculous how that stuff really does
catch up with you so yeah I just want to
become on Google is what I'm saying what
about you would you would you do it no
because I have my SEO and search engine
optimization wins on my website and you
know and there's ways to make your your
website less SEO friendly yeah yeah just
tag the wrong things link the wrong link
and the big thing is that there are
companies that you can actually pay to
bury all your search results so that you
know everything about you that's really
relevant or juicy or whatever is on the
seventh page of Google search when they
know that nobody ever goes I tweet you
know and I am oute on Twitter and I want
I obviously don't care and I obviously
want people to be reading that and
interact with people so part of me is
like now I don't want to be on Google
because I love to be able to communicate
with people and I love this
strangers it's better than Facebook like
the interaction you can have with just
people out there in the world on Twitter
then there is another part of me that's
like it's like in real life like what if
you just wanted to disappear like you
know there's something mysterious about
being able to think that there would be
a service that could make you just
disappear up the internet that's kind of
like sexy and I'm into it wasn't that
didn't Sandra Bullock do a movie and
that was yeah wasn't that sort of
someone erased her identity or something
or am i combining a crush on Sandra
Bullock which was not true because
honestly no one has a crush syndrome
oh you were still trying to be pretty
straight at that time I surprised but
you know what though isn't that funny
though how things happen so quickly like
when that movie the net came out with
Sandra Bullock it was supposed to be a
futuristic movie it didn't come out that
long ago maybe 15 years ago and it
already feels a thumb drive with
terrible graphics lawnmower man there's
like virtually killing people through
the weird computer world as before even
and on mowers and weird yeah things to
go after people yeah I was at my at my
grandma's house this weekend and she had
a CD that I wanted to take I don't even
have a CD player my computer doesn't
take CDs and I was like literally I
still have it I'm like I don't know what
how would I even get this device to be
put onto my computer at someone make
great coasters on there anyway
technology's going fast if you want to
disappear from Google there are people
that you can pay like in pretty much
everything else and speaking of people
you can pay so the next big trend at the
moment is that celebrities are jumping
all over Kickstarter and IndieGoGo
because they don't have enough of your
money they want more and the studio's
don't want to fork it over to them so
they want you to fund all their projects
so the the big ones people know about is
Zach Braff is getting the sequel to
Garden State made via Kickstarter and he
got the money but he got it in like
basically in about a half a second
through one tweet Veronica Mars is
coming back and it's gonna be
crowdfunded and then the new one now is
James Franco wants 500,000 bucks to get
a couple books that he wrote made into
movies and this seems very bizarre to me
because these people have more money
than all of us and they also want to
still take our money we also pay a lot
of money to go to their movies and all
that stuff it's like the height of just
Hollywood bull [ __ ]
Shawn absolutely worse but I feel like
when when the whole concept of
Kickstarter came about it was such a
great idea and it was cool for these
indie artists who needed some way to
make their crappy album you know and and
good ones too and actually logo had its
first ever crowd-sourced television
series called DTLA the air that was all
crowdsource and it didn't logo wasn't a
part of it until til later but I thought
that was interesting
so it was crowd-sourced and then made
its way to the network right I think
it's kind of with the way it should be
is that it starts out with a bunch of
people who don't have a ton of money
they put something together then someone
takes notice like a small TV channel and
puts on your project but already being
famous if you already have over five
hundred thousand dollars you shouldn't
ask poor people to submit to your
passion project yes I mean does this
just like the five hundred thousand also
from James Franco seems bonkers because
I'm sure the guy has millions of dollars
so like we're all out there putting our
stuff out there and working hard so why
should he have people that have less
money than him fund his project like
what's the psychological thing going
first of all part of it does say to me
he probably does have $500,000 that if
he really believed in his own project he
can invest in himself the way all of us
have invested in ourselves and with
whatever money in time we have you know
like normal people building themselves
up you're like if I have $10 that's
gonna go towards my career my internet
whatever it is that we're doing but you
know I'm not entirely mad at it I know
when Zach Braff did is people were
rolling their eyes and annoyed but a lot
of people really liked Garden State in
studios if you've ever work with a
studio before they're really impossible
they're not going to give you final
caught your vision isn't going to come
to fruition
gonna say you know well we need like a
bigger star or a better soundtrack we
want to change what you've written into
this this and that so I will say the
argument for some of these celebrities
is that they already have work with the
studios and probably haven't gotten even
show who they really are you know to
them to a James Franco or is that rapper
thinking well I've got to put out all
the stuff but it's been under you know
all these people in suits telling me
this is who I am in front of people so a
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo gives them the
opportunity to be like okay I'm an
artist that people already are familiar
with but here's how I would do it if I
were allowed to you gave me your money
this would be my vision rather than the
corporate vision we probably see most
the time right and as artists you're
speaking my language so why don't we
listen to the artist himself James
Franco tell us a little bit about what
you're doing to all help me adapt these
stories we just need a little bit more
help I'm just asking you for a little
more help I'm putting money into these
projects because I believe in them I
believe in these filmmakers and these
stories are very important to me and
very personal I find that this process
is very exciting but this is
be the best way to make movies because
in this way the movies we want to make
get made in the ways that we want to
make them
the only considerations are to make
possible goals are so not be aren't they
it's yeah and also I think it does go to
what you're saying of like when these
things started it was like let's get
water to children in Africa or you know
palates or something like that we're
just like that to you that were like we
want to make a cool movie but studios
won't listen to us because they're the
man so fund my movie about I mean their
Garden State esque movie that just had
nothing to do with the celebrity or that
crap there was a lot of that auto-tune
almost there I just need auto-tune young
or whatever she couldn't make her second
albums her first didn't do as well I
think it was her so she funded you know
her next album on that so people funded
their own projects that have had semi
fame I just don't think it was until
this Zac Franco thing that it's become
like a thing so on a personal level
would you guys cuz I have thought about
it I kinda I just generally don't like
the idea of asking for people I like
putting stuff out and then hopefully
finding like ancillary ways that you
make a dime off it but I can't say that
the thought has never crossed my mind to
be like look I do some good stuff that
people seem to enjoy and if everyone
that watched or listened or read my
tweets would give me a buck a month I'd
have a lot of money and I could probably
do this in 10 times greater way but
somehow that even feels a little slimy
to me does that feel like like that
you're asking when it's like - I've
actually it's it's I've had projects
where I thought I could put this on
IndieGoGo or Kickstarter and then
something about it made me feel strange
asking for money so maybe we need
therapy for that because clearly there's
no problem going saying I'm amazing pay
me for a great idea
Jan and I are gonna start a Kickstarter
for comedians that need therapy to be
able to accept Kickstarter money also I
have an idea I'm gonna start a
Kickstarter to stop rich people from
doing Kickstarter is showing any final
thoughts on this I I don't know one
Kickstarter thing I think is really
funny as I saw parents or potential
parents put a Kickstarter up to adopt a
child and I'm thinking if that's their
starting with the adoption process and
they're gonna have a Kickstarter for
school clothes are gonna have a
Kickstarter for college yeah they were
saying we need help to adopt a child and
they and as I that is they're in for a
rude awakening I think they think that
being a parents really inexpensive like
if you already don't have the resources
that's a little scary to me funded no
their aunts and uncles are like okay
I'll do this once but this is it kid
they ended up getting like a hundred
fifty bucks and they got okay all right
let's move on let's do a little gay
stuff haven't done anything gay in a
couple of weeks at least on the show
Jane Lynch who's I'd say she might be
America's top lesbian right now she's
right Ellen and her really fighting for
the top spot in the lesbian marathon I
guess she announced that she's getting
divorced from her partner of three years
and I thought this was interesting
because I feel like every gay person
feels that they have to be the perfect
gay person now in the perfect gay couple
and does a high profile gay person
getting divorced actually hurt the
movement for equality and we got DOMA
and prop 8 that are gonna be decided
this month by the Supreme Court and all
that stuff Sean as a noted homosexual
yeah I think that that we should accept
gay marriage and gay divorce because I I
know I'm not getting married to my
partner for the community I'm getting
married to my partner because I love him
and I want to marry him and I don't
think that I should be have to be held
up to a certain standard just for
political reasons right you know I don't
think we should be a couple that's like
having a terrible time we're going to
stay together just because is gonna say
yeah it just doesn't yeah you actually
are getting married no Julia no nothing
I'm not your humble but yeah so you feel
no X did you feel any extra pressure to
get married because I am feeling that a
little bit with the gay community too
that people that are in relationships
are feeling like they have to make a
political statement suddenly and say
that they're gonna get married no I I
thought that's just we're life we're
living our life like we're married
already we are drinking her Pinot Grigio
and and watching our DVR and going to
sleep and paying $50 a month for a gym
membership we never go to a nice parable
I know we're basically married so I
think just having our family there to
celebrate it is perfect
the right dad is a redneck but he loves
chip and he he's so excited to go to the
wedding and I and I'm actually gonna be
my only sibling that's gonna be married
there's straight siblings so I am
forging ahead for the Hollenbach name
yeah you're really changing the people
in rural Pennsylvania just go to my
Kickstarter for my adoption Jed what do
you think should gay people as a higher
standard for that should be so
ridiculous I'm stupid that anybody would
ever even if you're the type of [ __ ]
that's gonna be like those gay people
got divorced see gays can't get married
like go kill yourself and enjoy yourself
you're a nicer person I'm like no do
please do that was actually the best It
Gets Better campaign know that the
divorce rate for straight people is
pretty high so if people are gonna be
people they're not always gonna get
along things aren't always gonna work
out and it'd be nicer if more people
stay together and learn to work out
their problems with their partners
rather than being like well we had a
fight or or I want to go bang this
person so you know let's get divorced be
nicer straight people and you know gay
and lesbians all decided to work on
their relationships and stay together
but if you don't you should be able to
get out without worrying like that's
gonna be politicized or that now you're
gonna take away the ability for other
people to celebrate their love just
because like you married a douche the
way a single straight people end up
doing tit marry douches all the time
yeah isn't that the crazy part that you
know gay people feel this pressure to
get married then this feel this pressure
to not get divorce and it becomes this
sort of never-ending cycle when we just
want if it just goes to show if you just
give people equality they'll act just
like everyone else
right and then just like us do you fear
at all that like with all the Equality
one day when it's just all everything's
even and a kid can come out no one will
give a [ __ ] and a basketball player can
come out and it won't matter do you
think that the gays will actually lose
something that there is something
special about being different that's why
so much creativity comes out of gays but
the leather bars will all disappear yeah
I mean no really though do you think
that that's legit I think that the
community will lose like something
special yeah I feel like there's a there
is sort of an old gay versus new gay one
of one of your jokes is there our guy
old guys saying that I had to climb a
mountain does penis you know dick I know
I don't know if I could say it I don't
know if he can say I can say Jenny Sam
dick dick dick dick dick okay
got it back in our day we had to suck
dick yeah we had to climb up hill to
suck dick it's an old joke right but I
feel like there's still there's still a
subset of people that are saying I
remember when New York was fun and being
gay was fun I think being gay is just as
fun now as it ever was still doing the
same things it's not I I don't see what
the big differences people are different
to some people are gay are gonna want to
know live in New York City and party and
you know suck different dick and then
there's gonna be other gay people
they're just like whoa I want to be in a
monogamous relationship and I just want
that one exactly just one dick or China
as it may be so a British I mean that's
like saying penis vagina what's the what
are lesbians refer to the vaginas do
they say vagina to each other see the
flower
Georgia O'Keeffe yeah but that isn't
that concept though about the the sort
of longing for the old days that's what
that Woody Allen movie Midnight in Paris
was about that we always think that
something before us and it just wasn't
right like do you I mean do you think
back on something some other time and
think it was probably better but there
was a lot of bad [ __ ] going on - I'm
from New York I romanticize in New York
and old New York and I think about
walking through the city streets and how
beautiful it was and I don't think about
how half the time I was like I can't get
a cab I don't think about all the misery
that I romanticized past relationships
and think about the great things about
them when I'm in a current one that's
not necessarily as romantic or as
special as that one so we all
romanticize the past we like to do that
so you don't have to confront our
current situation we get so much better
when X Y Z yeah
when there were subway murders I missed
that the bad stuff they were serial
murders out in New York City and air
conditioning in the subways do we still
do we have orchid no there's air
conditioning now but there was a time
when there wasn't which i think is crazy
just I don't miss that all right well
we've got one more story for you and I
think you guys are gonna dig this one
which is they're hot right now there is
a pagan academy in New York City where
they are training Wiccans and witches
I'm being a little good about this but
it's a it's a real thing that actually
probably is legitimate as any other
religion out there and as someone that's
trained in the Jedi arts I really
shouldn't be making fun of this okay so
it was established the Wiccan family
Temple Academy of pagan studies was
established in 2007 and you know they're
teaching Wiccan studies so this of
course it lends itself to a lot of jokes
and are they flying around on brooms and
is it like Hogwarts Academy and all that
but do you think just these sort of
offshoot random things are as legit as
the big three religions that we talk
about all the time I would say no not
because of the religion itself I would
say so I went to their website and their
main font is Comic Sans
so that's what I would say I don't think
they're legit based on that reason I
don't go to restaurants if they have
Comic Sans
yeah I'm still like Comic Sans and then
it became the joke of the fund right
it's the same it's just like oh I want
to be creative but I'm not really funny
your joke your stand out the comic cent
okay so here's the thing yes I feel like
most girls not all girls and people are
gonna be in the comment section like
you're a crazy [ __ ] I was ever wicked I
feel like a lot of girls go through a
phase where you decide to explore
witchcraft and be Wiccan for me it
happened twice one time it was like in
junior high and we were like let's
probably cuz the craft or something like
that exactly you're like let's be dark
and evil and we're dark it's almost like
you're weird goth but you think you're
Wiccan and then another period in
college where they're all these like you
know indie bookstores that had a lot of
Wiccan books and I would read them and
and I was like this is kind of cool it's
kind of like nature and the elements and
it makes sense and it seems like a
religion that's less you know has a
string gold on what you do and or does
kind of harm no one and do what you will
I think is the Wiccan credo I think you
don't have to sit in a room and stand up
sit down stand up sit down the idea of
harm no I didn't do what you will isn't
harming anyone that's their credo by
nature is that you don't harm other
people and it's kind of interesting so
I'll say I think a lot of people do go
girls in particular I don't know about
men go through a wick and exploration
period when you're a teenager right did
you ever do anything did you try to
concoct day did you put lizards I and a
dish going on but they do have a certain
I think you're interested in it
especially when we were young when I was
in junior high dude that face we're like
let's cast spells to make this boy like
God but you're so innocent not you know
you're like oh Bobby he's so cute on the
football team if we all sit here and it
was almost like a seance with a Ouija
board really make them like us that's
really creepy creepier than I thought
would come out yeah but I think you know
you go through these different phases
where you explore different things and
there's nothing wrong with this academy
existing it's obviously I mean it's just
like there's a lot of religions that
make ton of money like Scientology that
people think are an offshoot and it's a
huge religion and also just even
Catholicism and the Anglican Church was
a spinoff of that so there's different
spin-offs of all different sorts of
religions and just accepted it exists
and people want to be which is cool yeah
is also part of it though that the other
three the big three religions we are so
inundated with their images like if you
really when you watch you know they get
a new poll
and it's so over-the-top and crazy and
the outfits and the hat I mean the whole
thing so freakin gay and it's so bonkers
and yet when I read this so High
Priestess star Raven hawk guessing
that's not her given name she told The
Times if people really knew what we were
about they would know that studying to
become a good witch is no different than
studying to become a good Catholic and I
bet that probably is true so maybe none
of it's that great how about that all
the religions yeah like they're in a
witch's hat and the other ones in a big
pointy hat I mean what's the difference
what they all have hats
I know I don't support anything I can't
prove all religion to me is I think it's
fun to have and it's fun to have
tradition but I believe in the universe
yeah you believe we're here right now
that's that's pretty much what I don't
know you can't prove it yeah yeah I
believe we're here right now do you
think we're here right now get real
weird if we're not here right now then
where are we that would be in that weird
cool down plant like really being
incubated there and no okay so the
Wiccan thank you quick getting back to
whatever I understand I guess maybe your
question is like are people paying money
to go to a church that doesn't exist or
being offered you know skills in
witchcraft and is this really be a
that's more Bunker like really is there
anyone that's more bonkers like we all
seem to think that Scientology maybe is
more bonkers than this one because
they're putting Tom Cruise in a steam
room with a bunch of guys or whatever
all religions are bonkers to me or
equally as interesting where can I have
or could have equal meaning to certain
people so you know I don't want to crap
on people's religions or support them
because for me it's kind of all the same
I just feel like you know every Wiccan
that's the same thing as being Catholic
to me they're all the same like you know
choose what you will and if you if that
makes you feel better to believe in it
great and if not you know be
thinking person and maybe think things
through and don't just blindly follow
religion and be a thinking person that's
pretty that's pretty do you guys think
some of this though has to do with
movies because I saw a study that in
England that like the fifth highest
religion the fifth highest ranked
religion really is Jedi I mean people in
the census put down Jedi and then if you
think about the witch thing I mean Harry
Potter is pretty popular but more this
stuff pops up in pop culture like people
are gonna start believing in really sort
of more bonkers things like unicorns
like yes I am gonna make them come to
life that's our thing instead of thing I
believe in the universe you're supposed
to say I believe in you never all right
well on that note we've wrapped this
whole thing up so Shawn I'm gonna let
you tell people about your unicorns
first talk to camp manager to get ready
for a new book called unicorns on
computer paper coming out TBD and follow
me at Shawn Hollenbach on Twitter
excellent Jen hi I am Jen Hoffman who
wishes I was on Google but since I'm not
you can follow me on Twitter at
gentlemen which is je and an H o FF ma
and not the photographer who people
think is me on there yeah forget about
that lady and I'm Dave Rubin you can
follow me on twitter at reuben report i
hope you're doing that already and just
a little shout out to all you NSA guys
out there we dig what you're doing and
to all you
Wiccans and what else did we cover today
all you James Franco good luck with that
yeah thanks guys we'll see you next week